My name's Ingrid Avendaå˜o and I'm an intern at Jawbone. I'm, I've been going to
school for art for three years and then I switched over to electrical
engineering. The reason I started that was it started off as a bet with another
friend and then the notion started off that I couldn't learn how to program.
And I kind of feel a little bit spiteful, and be like no I can do this, I, I
can prove them wrong. I, I signed up for, or into the computer science course
and that whole semester like it was really, really like terrifying to get into.
Because I had no idea what I was doing, but by the time finals rolled around
and I'm just. The whole semester had passed where I'm like, I can't do this, I
don't think I can do this and I got my final grade. And then I was like, wow, I
actually enjoyed this. Which was kind of something I wasn't expecting, but
after that I kind of decided, you know what, this is something that I haven't
enjoyed in years. Just having challenging problems that, like I'm excited to
sit there and program for hours. I'm like I'm going to solve this, I'm going to
do it and so I decided I had to do something different and I decided well I'm
going to try to do electrical engineering. Its a little bit more hands on with
hardware. But I still got that programming element. So that's what leads me to
do an internship at Jawbone and I've been doing three years of electrical
engineering at the University of Pittsburgh.